Sascha Keil is an historian and leading
member of the 300 strong Berlin
underworld association
their headquarters is a wartime air-raid
shelter hidden under a subway station
their mission to uncover the lost
history of underground Berlin over the
past 10 years
they found a secret city beneath the
streets locating a hundred bunkers and
charting more than 25 miles of tunnels
in the process they've created a
detailed picture of the Nazi capital
their detective work is invaluable in
understanding Hitler's Berlin because
today's city looks nothing like it did
in 1945 Allied forces destroy 90% of
Berlin bombers pound the city day and
night
then over two brutal weeks the Russian
army blasts its way street by street
into the city center to finally end the
conflict after the war the Allies
flattened many of Hitler's key buildings
destroying most traces of the Nazi
regime but underground a network of
bunkers and tunnels survives providing a
gateway back to everyday life in Nazi
Germany
British historian Anthony beaver has
written the definitive account of the
fall of Berlin together with Kyle and
his team they head off limits into the
dangerous depths of the humble time
tower it's on the right side now right
around corner we have many thousands of
cubic meters of rubble so with this
great big curve on it is it still safe
is it safe
yes I can say because of the strong
steel nets they are still intact though
beavers written extensively about
wartime Berlin this is a world he's
never seen before so the next level this
is the third level yeah and you see it's
a middle of the building yes look at
that